hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is our you garbage I am your host H
Foley this is where we sit down with
some of your favorite comedians and we
find that if they grew up classy or if
they grow up trashy my co-host coming at
you from an undisclosed location down
there somewhere in the southern part of
New Jersey Kevin James Ryan everybody
hey what's up everybody still down here
in the bunker living to fight another
day you know what I mean
heatherandmike and foods might my cured
meats we're doing it he was the first
man on the lifeboat folks did not wait
for women and children he was out yes I
do
I had an inside tip from a guy who knows
a guy who knows the guy and back in like
you know early January he's like get the
[ __ ] out of town so I [ __ ] his his
insights happy to be here thanks for
shout out to all the new listeners all
the new reviews all the new subscribers
we're getting driven a lot by Louis J
Gomez we appreciate it
make sure you rate review subscribe you
can subscribe on YouTube for all the
full videos of the episodes and stuff
like that and we appreciate the support
guys absolutely thank you so much and we
got another big get here on the podcast
today our good pal very funny stand-up
comedian he has an album out right now
called Rage Against the routine he's on
the Irish goodbye podcast performs all
over the country and let me tell you
kids something else too this guy's got a
tick tock account with a [ __ ]
flamethrower on it he's hot on tick tock
he's big
ladies and gentlemen our pal Mike Feeny
wow what an intro I mean just yeah you
know I always know you to be one of the
best hosts in terms of bringing me up on
stage when we when com member when
comedy existed and even now it
translates your skills translate very
well like I said you're a good host when
you bring people onstage not when you're
performing comedy listen once the bunch
your attempted company is through when
you then bring up the other actual good
comedians one eight and then you're
great once you build us up in earnest
we're really appreciative I tell you
what I'm a bomb up front but I'll never
launch an intro baby I think it's a
Tonight Show
I'm
for the band the strike up Mycenae
everybody yeah I I do have some
observations right now first thing you
gonna is your name is your middle name
really James Kevin yes
yeah really Kevin is it really yeah what
do you [ __ ] smash more dead of core
doom is you can even join me as Kevin
James Ryan for literally seven years I
thought already because of Kevin James
yeah you just got to ride that wave I'm
trying to get into grown-ups 19 no yeah
no it's Kevin James yeah Kevin James
Ryan Wow and Foley if anybody should be
going by Kevin James to try and ride the
wave I feel like you should be the the
heir apparent you know paul blart mall
cop this time he's an astronaut he works
in space force what I follow what I do
love about your setup is you're in like
pseudo darkness but you have one plant
that you're making staring at itself in
its own reflection and it's growing
towards itself do you notice that it's
very true detective yeah yeah I got eyes
baby I'm scanning everything here yeah I
know yeah I see you checking out the
headboard and all that kind of stuff
scoping around got a yoga mat back there
you got a nice picture nice dresser nice
bed everything's all set about my girl
she does a good job this is great you
got the guitar hanging up which means
I'll never come to a dinner party your
house I think the good part is I'm not I
don't know enough guitar that I learned
like four core I don't know how to Barre
chord I've hit a wall in my learning and
I'm really not breaking through that
threshold hey seems like you stopped the
learning as you after the purchase
you're like alright I had learned as
much as I don't have to buy one Hey
after that I'm done I can play free
fallin by Tom Petty and that's all I
need pal because have you ever been over
at somebody's house and there's like a
little bit of a party some people around
and all sudden someone just starts
playing the guitar a little bit and then
all of a sudden they're singing you're
like what they're missing chords going
back you like come on now can I throw it
again folk over here shakes ear dude
what are you doing do this cover what
the [ __ ] can I throw this out there
there's two things that only will bother
me if the guitarist wants to be the
singer and have everybody staring at him
I don't
if a guitarist comes out and has
everybody else sing like campfire style
that okay that's fine I'll tell you this
that might be okay but here's the this
is the adult version of why when that's
great you're at a party and the party
has a [ __ ] piano and somebody sits
down and starts [ __ ] tickling the
ivories yeah but if somebody could play
the piano that's a lot different than
some schmuck trying to play [ __ ] no
woman no cry on if you can [ __ ] play
the skins baby do that's you got pal
first off the piano is the only
instrument that gets cooler as you get
older and we were like I'm like what the
[ __ ] is this and now I look at him like
man if I could [ __ ] tickle those
ivories yeah you had a piano in your
house yeah well not the full one you had
like one that wasn't like a speakeasy
like dude yeah I mean I didn't have a
[ __ ] grand piano in the four yeah you
[ __ ] idiot of course it was a [ __ ]
stand-up piano yeah have you been at the
left wing of my own grand piano
kippis like Liberace coming down the
steps hello mother I always wanted to
play it and then it was kind of it
played itself at one point I remember
that to like turn it on to play a song
you just had a player piano from a mall
that you guys stole one time an old
Western I was dressed as the bartender
day Gibby grew up in a ghost town in the
Old West there I was supposed to play
piano when I was a kid but then my
parents started price checking a couple
of pianos and that got any sick yeah you
landed on the recorder a real [ __ ]
Claire I paid 6 bucks
apparently I wanted to learn how to play
piano I expressed interest in that and
my grandmother went so far as to get me
like a like a keyboard you know I mean
just like a keyboard thing and then I
just never learned or try
keyboard was garbage the keyboard we
really we had the Casio keyboard and you
know with the button you hit that
[ __ ] Samba beat that's as far as I
could go
dude let that sound will be run whoo the
90s were a good time yes oh yeah that
was pretty trashy man because you never
I never you nobody ever had to stand you
put it on your lap [ __ ] this dan was an
extra like $49.99 no [ __ ] way was my
mom springing for that and the warranty
were left at the store you know what I'm
sayin dude I don't know if it's garbage
but I have never bought a warranty in
Milo it's the opposite warranty is
garbage if cuz Warne the piece of [ __ ]
Trix are the only people who buy
warranties are poor trash people who
don't know any better
okay I always felt like it was more of
like an educated thing with money of
like you hedge your bets I'm like yeah
I'll give you the 39 bucks just in case
anything that is that's what they want
dumb people to think as I have this
whole time I've been a [ __ ] genius
millionaire over there I had the
insurance or '[ __ ] I had the insurance
for the phone for a long time that was a
call like insurer or something like that
where I paid like 50 bucks a year or
something and at the end of it like when
I finally needed it they were like okay
you gotta send us the broken phone then
we'll send you a new phone for 200 bucks
I'm like 200 that's what about the
[ __ ] money I've been paying it to it
it's always that way did we add what did
we just buy I bought Oh so I had I had
like a soundbar from my TV for I think
six I had it for six years and one month
and the warranty expired after six years
I had a couch that has like motorized
like legs like it's like you know like
the feet will come up and the motor on
it broke right but your monthly gas I
picture Feeny like I gotta take a nap
yeah I didn't do enough oil changes on
it so you got robotic furniture that's
garbage
yeah well here's even more garbage it
brokes and now one of them is like
permanently up like you can try and like
use your leg power but and once you
stand up it kicks back up again and we
won't want to throw it out because it's
a three seat couch and it's very
comfortable and otherwise it's
completely fine but they told me that
not only is it out of warranty but that
the motor has stopped working so and
they don't make the part anymore so the
guy just basically was like you're out
sucks I don't know
I was coming in here to defend you as a
classy individual did you hit me with
that story now what he's [ __ ] Long
Island tre I think he's farm team that's
real garbage yeah yeah you got a
triple-a team pissed grants grandma the
[ __ ] the iron pigs from Bethlehem PA
yeah now I say Feeny's classy and I'll
tell you why no no way dude no [ __ ]
away he's long [ __ ] true everybody
we've had on from Long Island has never
made a pass like the second question and
that was when I got a broken couch with
the white come on it's a very nice couch
I should have called beforehand told you
two eighty simcha I got a story straight
we went up against Kippy so what am I go
to guy you know that he even doubled
down on the garbage because bullets a
nice couch that's a garbage thing you
don't want to throw out a nice couch
even though it's [ __ ] broken and what
the [ __ ] is a soundbar which there was
only a Sunday very fancy thing to have
it's because your TV audio is so shitty
it's like just a sound it justice plays
the sound from your TV and video games
like the thing that goes under the TV or
above the TV it's like a long-serving a
woofer is it a woofer no woofer is just
bass don't keep saying woofer like
literally what was that I've never seen
anybody get so weirded out over a word I
like a woofer see that's why that's why
I don't think he's garbage because he
always calls me out on my garbage stuff
and I think i repulse him fat guys can
all the guy's fat it's the it's not
mutually exclusive all right well let's
find out let's get into it here I'll get
into it are you garbage we got Mike
Feeny on the line here as we know album
out right now called rage against a
routine huge on tick tock follow him
everywhere Irish goodbye podcast hippie
says the kids garbage I say he's a
classy guy and I have my reasons
well we're here about the fire
out right now ah monkey where did you
grow up did you go up on Long Island
Long Island New York out in Suffolk
County New York which is not the
classiest that's not the good one oh
well aware pal yeah
it was [ __ ] I was I grew up
five-one-six-- area code oh they got too
many people they had to split it up and
then they gave the five-one-six-- to the
rich people in Nassau County and gave me
the 631 so I was rather die but you have
a couple of dealers that at 6:31 when I
came up it was gonna be a little bit of
a wait I'm coming in from the island I'm
waiting I'm waiting on a train the Li is
a mess I grew up in like a very you know
like I I don't know we're in the middle
class it was but like we were suburbs
you know but there was also like someone
on our block had like a car on their
front lawn you know then my next-door
neighbors had like a giant beautiful
in-ground pool so it was really like a
house to house sure that's how that's
what we're finding out you know the
suburbs especially to because like so I
grew up in like a really nice area it
was all like doctors and lawyers and
[ __ ] but like I was my family my dad was
a like he was a steam fitter he was like
he like but then he started his own
company so like there was like the
blue-collar guy you know like the
blue-collar families of the area and
then like the white-collar families and
it's like from house to house it was
like it changes yeah my house had a shed
in the back that's still not finished to
this day you know it was like oh we're
gonna build this and then just never
done in unfinished projects so when a
bag of soil or like mulch has just been
sitting out on the front lawn for four
bags of mulch yeah my parents marriage
it all just because of things they were
gonna keep doing but to quit because my
dad always [ __ ] about that because
our neighborhood is it is very similar
that it's it's it's middle-class all the
way but you have new people moving in
people you know buying their parents
houses you know put money back into the
ass cleaning it up trying to get the
property value up and my dad did that
you know I think he put a lot of a lot
of work into the house and they'll be
like two or three days
that will drive by it'll be like what
the [ __ ] yeah Congrats is overrun
there's caught your cars in the [ __ ]
yeah it brings the whole property value
down at the whole neighborhood you know
we I'm looking I'm thinking about like
my across-the-street neighbor owned like
a spackle company my my next-door
neighbors were police like he was like a
undercover like narcotics officer and
stuff and really that's the guy who was
calling Foley funny stories so I grew up
with the you know he was the father I
used to hang out with his kids because
they were like closer to my age and I
went away to college and then I went
into the city for college my head and
then my family moved my mom moved down
the Florida so I hadn't gone back so I
hadn't seen him in in years and then I
was in Times Square like transferring
trains and I saw him like on the job he
was like working with a couple other
police officers and I came up to him and
was like I was like [ __ ] 18 or
something and I was like what's up Sam
and like like patted his shoulder and
like give him like a hey and like he
just gave me like this look of being
like he he initially was very alarmed
and then decompressed and was like yeah
usually we don't we don't let people
touch us we don't we don't let any gets
run up and like you know [ __ ] the TAS
but yeah I realize also [ __ ] Feeny
almost got this guy clipped he's
standing there with four dominican guys
in suits what do you got well you were
right now you know this guy's a killer
is the Feeny pulls the thing from blow
and deck so I try to grab my dick and I
realized you trying to grab my prick
what we called it my Center reach was
the town it cuz it was right in the
middle of Long Island but but it always
was referred to as like Santa Rico which
I always thought was this like cool like
we're like tough like yo we come say no
Rico and then I'm realizing now it's
just because everybody was Puerto Rican
she realize it was a heavily part my
neighbors were Puerto Rican everybody's
worried like that was a weird thing we
grew up with diversity but a weird type
of diversity like we always there was
like a tayo
was friends like a ton of Spanish kids
Tenneco Rican kids ton of Asian and
Filipino kids but there weren't like and
a lot of like so many Jewish and Italian
people that like I couldn't even tell
them apart you know cuz she was Long
Island to tell you among Islander the
same [ __ ] thing but but we didn't have
like I had like three black friends that
were in my neighborhood and the rest of
that was like that was that that was the
only thing where it lacked some
diversity yeah
did you need over you know where the
Spanish kids houses yeah dinner yeah
that's good I see a lot well then they
had five kids because of course and it
was a lot of that in there it would be
like you know rice and beans and stuff
which I loved about in my house but I
problem was I was like such a crazy
eater when I was a kid I would get so
hungry I'd be like eating like plates
full and then they were babysitting me
and they had to eventually be like yeah
we got to save food for the rest of the
family you're like eating all avoiding
there yes a big eater man he does eat a
lot first what's your mentality you
spider-man what you metabolism I have a
very very high metabolism for now though
cuz my dad is 6 1 to 80 and so he was
not yeah and he used to be my size but
here's the thing he never he worked at
UPS for a while when I was growing up so
he was like like manual labor like was
like in that kind of shape and then he
transitioned he like ended up quitting
that became a stockbroker and ever since
then he's been sitting down for 20 years
so he's been so now it's just all
guinness and he doesn't ever he's never
belong to a gym you know hey what a
[ __ ] career change will goes from UPS
the [ __ ] stockbroker what are those
yeah he's a he's like a senior Wealth
Advisor now he was he was literally like
yo he was in UPS he decided to quit with
his buddy to start a small business and
then right after they both quit like it
was a two-prong effect of the guy who
the guy who he was going into business
with like got cold feet and backed out
and then also he found out that like if
he had stated is the UPS for like
another I don't know like couple months
or whatever they all got like crazy
promoted so like he like tried to not
avoid a quick narrow mental breakdown
there and midlife crisis but then yeah
came up the other side but
did your dad go to college so he went to
yeah he went to a bunch of different
colleges I know he went to like he
bounced around he did like a year like
Wisconsin he went to NYU for a little
while but I know he got his he got his
master's from from Dowling which is no
longer a school anymore it was a Long
Island school they would always play
this it was like a dish soap company
yeah but always play this commercial and
it had this this this little song theme
that they would go and they would go
downs the college on a river bank on
banks of the whole world I don't even
know what I meant but that was the song
that they would play every 40 seconds
and now it's a business the reason I
asked is because my brother he worked on
Wall Street for about 15 15 years or so
and the dudes that I always liked the
most like all of the people that he
would bring around were the guys like
that who got into it later and didn't go
to some of them didn't go to college if
they got if they got in like in they're
in their 40s in like the 80s of the 90s
they didn't they weren't college guys
they were like street guys right yes
used to selling like washing machines
exactly so in a Kenmore double unit you
know tell me this pen yeah exactly
going out to dinner with them was
awesome all right let's get in here and
find out mr. Feeny not looking good so
far
[Laughter]
I got one for you have you ever worn an
Oracle of echo or g-unit clothing
clothes I back in seventh grade I wore I
had a FUBU jacket it was my favorite
jacket my mom bought it for me at like
Marshalls or Kmart or something yeah
yeah actually probably a Bob's discount
store not the clothing furniture store
but so she got me this it was this
reversible fleece lined waterproof
outside like red [ __ ] jacket I love
this thing and I went to public school
up until 7th grade and then I went to
this weird private school for two years
and then I went to a different private
school for high school but I this the
seventh grade is my first day of
grade and I went in the school went from
seventh grade to twelfth grade which is
way too many grades because if you're
seventh grader a senior is [ __ ]
they're monsters so their own man
compared to children yes so I get off
the bus and I'm walking into the
auditorium for like the first day in
this new school of like meeting
everything and as I was walking into the
building I can't ever forget it there
was there was like two or three like
senior dudes who were both black and
they just stopped me and we're like you
know that jacket means and I was like uh
comfortable you know I didn't know that
he just was like all literally leet like
leaned over me and they look like like
the Monstars from Space Jam all are they
were than me they were like it's for us
by us and I was like okay well I don't
ever need to wear this coat again and
then I never wore it again that's crazy
because I asked because of you know a
lot of white trash kids suburbs you know
like outside of the cities at that age
because the world I think we're about
the same age echo and g-unit like that
was like the coolest [ __ ] I would have
never thought to ask for a [ __ ] FUBU
shirt that's I didn't ask for it my mom
just probably no but I'm saying I would
I never would have thought to ask on
this show have you ever worn a FUBU yeah
yeah oh yeah I mean I also had like I
went through that trend of like the huge
like Genco jeans and [ __ ] like that yeah
trial dude don't judge what was in I'm
telling you no fun there's no way a
[ __ ] Kennedy went to school wearing
Jenko nobody expense jeans by accident
wore a FUBU t-shirt for the black guys I
know that much Mikey you ever wear
sunglasses on top of your baseball hat
never never in my life no ever wear a
bandana under a baseball hat no I'm not
I'm such an infrequent hat guy dad when
I wear hats that's the only thing I'm
wearing okay I went up there was a
couple of kids a couple of white kids
and Michael junior high school it's more
do rags uh well I will say we going bald
oh no no they were just thought they
they wanted to be
I because again because my Puerto Rican
neighbors where his his cousin one of
their cousins would come from Brooklyn
all the time and hang out and he always
wore a do-rag so we were at the mall he
convinced me I bought a do-rag in one of
these kiosks but I never wore it because
once I got at home I realized like that
it wouldn't do for my hair what it does
for his it's functional yeah things
where that wave white dudes wear them as
like yo this is cool cuz black guys wear
black guys wear I mean as it's it's
functional right it see Feeny walking
around the mall looking like a B smooth
[Laughter]
alrighty moving right along I was gonna
ask you dear do you have a sectional
couch that has a built-in coaster system
and it put you already got the loveseat
with the [ __ ] with the robot it's a
three-person baby
lucky for you we got luxury plush
Raymour and Flanigan that's good good I
got payment plans what are you talking
about that's because it's so expensive
none of you guys can afford Raymour and
Flanigan you look down upon me with your
nose that's why I don't chop if I did
shop there would how it would be able to
payment plan I'm more of a knight of an
Ikea use section bike oh yeah I've never
got a piece of furniture that I'd have
to put together myself for something
some degree even my parents your chair I
bought from Staples and I paid the extra
money to have them put it together
that's pretty good it saves you the
headache for sure I mean dude every time
I plan I put a bed together I must
[ __ ] killed my wife of course yeah
alright I have you ever tried to sell
weed of course I was in college and
smoked weed how everybody who smokes
weed I didn't start smoking weed till I
was like a senior in high school so
nobody that starts smoking around that
age doesn't have the thought of like but
if I buy it in bulk that is I only got a
cell until that what I was doing like
weed math all the time sure of course
you know I tried to sell in college for
a little while and then I got like you
know it was never it was like I'd buy
like an ounce like it wasn't even like a
lot and trying to split up sell like
grams of people and then immediately at
like house parties was like oh this'll
be great at house parties the [ __ ]
make some cash and then they were like
people would be like this is where we
sell weird like the weed guys here and
I'm like okay I'll just smoke all right
cool I'll just smoke all that sounds
good bro that's always what happened you
end up smoking way too much of it
wait so you got muscled out of that he
got muscled off the corner I got I got
muscled off the corner dawg yeah the
Chess Club really gave it to him hey
beat it Feeny
stringer bell over here yeah dude this
is a guy named Tex he was like a big
[ __ ] Texas football bleach-blond
dirty blonde hair big like grizzled
thing he was uh yeah he was he liked to
scrap did I don't I don't [ __ ] with
anybody named Tex anybody that goes by
the name text you you you operate in any
way you want to operate big man so you
know especially if they're not from
Texas now he was garbage he's the reason
that I've never done cocaine because I
watched him in a house party one time
everybody it was one of those house
parties it was like really late at night
it was getting to the early morning
hours and I guess a bunch people started
to leave but then a bunch of people went
into the kitchen and it was only him and
I in the living room and he just set up
like six rails and then just did them
one by one and then just was like like
staring at me afterwards and I'm like
that's the grossest thing I've ever seen
I don't need to do that I don't think oh
man Foley only if you meant tanks back
in the night [ __ ] you wouldn't be
where you're at right now I know that
much hey cokes gross am i right kids in
college and I realized I all my friends
were doing blow like a lot you know like
we you know in the weekends and [ __ ] you
know Wednesdays whatever it's dollar
beers you know so you get everybody
would do blows like and we'd stay up
till I never did it but why we would
stay up till 7:00 in the morning
drinking and then it's like you know a
year two of that I'm like oh they're
only up because of the blow I'm like
fast an alcoholic you know and I'm like
dude it would be like 6:00 in the
morning they're all like [ __ ] strung
around I'm like barely keep my eyes open
I'm like I gotta keep drinking just like
a [ __ ] you feel like a kid we're like
isn't it cool how late we're staying up
yeah
I was like this is awesome yeah let's
party they're all like it's sort of
business dude yeah that's one you know
you have a drinking problem when you're
down with the crazy coke ideas
that's funny Feeny you never smoke did
your cigarettes um no cuz I smoked weed
before cigarettes so I never got the
appeal I've sprung I've smoked probably
like less than a pack my entire life I
in college I would like be drunk outside
of a bar and someone give me one but I
never bought one of my own I never got
it okay alright I got it I know you like
you like the sauce you're big you know
you're an IRA is an Irish man by heart
you like you like you like drinkin pops
every now and then do your parents drink
and what do they drink they do my dad is
forever was like a beer guy but you know
what beer Budweiser heavy but heavy and
Guinness I mean he would he could recite
the entire Budweiser label you know
those like like this otherwise are they
proud America but it's like six lines
him and his friends used to like get
drunk and like recited to each other and
whenever you get a wrong drink but no he
was like he was a big into that he
doesn't like light beers he started he
started getting it to craft beer a
little bit but he's not a real he'll
have one but it's not his preference but
now he's trying to look after his figure
a little bit more so he's I switch and
he's like gin and tonics classy
middle-of-the-road not too shabby are ya
Kippy why did you make that face about
the Budweiser he was uh will you
expecting something different he worked
at UPS in the stock broker what's the
use gonna say Moscow mules my guy yeah
big still a guy who knew no I I just
Budweiser can be Budweiser can walk in
both worlds Budweiser can be trashy if
you're trash or you know hey but heavies
are a [ __ ] American drink and I'm a
patriot hey what'd you get a [ __ ]
nice bud bottle in the summer that's
screaming cold ain't nothing wrong with
a BH I'm listening
that be up with two all right I got
another one did growing up did you or
any of your relatives have horseshoe
pits in your bag no no it did not
that was not a thing oh wait wait a
minute
hippie with the grand jury testimony I I
think actually my grandfather by my
grandparents house they mr. Feeny do not
live in or did you ever knock a
horseshoe pit in their defense though
they were born in 1920 so that was like
all of the fun you could have video
games I remember we had my dad my doing
my dad's house we were having a big
barbecue and he's like I'm doing it and
we went out we built these company
building we dug we put sand we put what
I thought we were the [ __ ] coolest
kids on the block I looking back we were
trash I used to bartend at my
grandparents you things have a big like
wedding anniversary party every year and
I would bartend at like 7:00 I was like
I was making scratch dude trying to wet
your beak you need a Michelob I got you
what do you need yeah yeah yes something
that determines how trashy war is that
what age did you learn how to pour a
draft beer oh you know what I mean yeah
draft I never had really my uncle had
like a keg out of the tap yeah I got it
a keg but my dad somebody at some point
in in high school my dad had converted
like this 1950s fridge to a beer Meister
and that thing sat in our garage for
like 25 years so anytime there was a
party and the pitchers had to get filled
up they'd send me and my brother to do
it right we learned how to keep it on an
angle yeah don't respect somebody who
can't pour a beer of course you give
them you give them that bottle and the
glass and then you just [ __ ] look two
outs two minutes later they have two
ounces of beer no I like what the [ __ ]
are we doing here
people worn a silver spoon in their
mouth I'm talking about hey what about
the sloppy joe Feeny how do you feel
about the sloppy joe I'm like sloppy joe
just my name is trash yeah it's a very
camp thing to have you know
I've never I've had Safi joes my mama
has absolutely made stoppages like
manwich man whichever sandwich comes in
a can it's [ __ ] trash okay
are you what about people have tuna
depends on the application of the said
tuna okay
chicken of the sea tuna salad yeah I
mean first you know it's not what any
Nobel [ __ ] prizes for sure but it's
you know it's all we have now it's
either your trash or you're getting to
know your laureate
and a can of tuna yesterday yeah but you
ate it with the fork out of it he ate he
ate the whole can actually I always put
a little bit of mayo and relish in it
that's how I do my tuna salad relish and
yeah it's good and I tell you what if
sloppy joes are wrong I don't want to be
right here's my sandwich was it good
sloppy joe on a regular hamburger bun
with a couple of [ __ ] kettle cooked
chips and a [ __ ] nice cold Saudi he's
just about to tell you my tuna salad
recipe which is a little bit of mayo I
cut up some Keuka neck you can where's
our celery and some red onion but then
my favorite thing to put on it on some
toast with tuna salad is Lay's sour
cream and onion with that little crunch
in there the chips on chips on a
sandwich is pretty garbage but it's
[ __ ] oh dude chips on a sandwich good
[ __ ] night all day long yeah while
we're on this tip I might as well ask
you this because I got this in the in
the chamber and this goes out to both of
you
you don't need its general question I'm
unfamiliar with how podcasting works
continue if you're having chips and
salsa okay or any kind of chips and dip
and you get down to the end of the bag
or the crumbs are and yeah and any are
at the end of the dip have you ever
taken those chips dump them into the dip
and then ate the stuff with the spoon I
honestly never even considered that for
a second I've done something maybe worse
which is I just grabbed as much of the
clump in my finger here and get my
fingertips dripping down Wow man the end
of a
of [ __ ] Tostitos will show you who
you really [ __ ] sad pathetic life my
friend my god be abyss staring back at
you I never thought to make a [ __ ]
jell-o pudding with chips that you have
great I would lie if I said I have I
done both of those it is in history for
sure yeah oh man if there's just not a
mirror at the bottom of that bag of
chips showing you what you [ __ ] hate
about yourself oh god what are you doing
to yourself Foley a 700 pairs what are
you doing oh my god that's too funny
that's great please go ahead okay
alrighty good cop bad cop this Punk have
you ever put a sound system in your car
or a head unit which was yes yes yes
buddy you're talking to a guy who lived
in Long Island you know so I not only
had one but I worked at Best Buy so I
got this crazy discount I had a my first
car was a 1988 Buick Skyhawk which is
not a Skylark yeah when they kept making
this was a sky Hawk that I got for free
that my cousin was gonna donate but to
charity but instead gave it to me as my
first car and I put a 12 inch sub woofer
in there a pioneer amplifier I put about
like like $700 or more of like sound
system into a thing that only had a
radio until that way and had like manual
locks like it was just the the oldest
car but it [ __ ] bomb through that
thing rattled I loved it I could see
that even wear a hat sideways I mean you
weren't a hat sideways didn't you I may
be tried after watching The Fresh Prince
but I never it always hurt my head never
made sense to me yeah yeah I tried to do
I tried to I don't have had in here but
I tried to engineer my own style which
was it was what would how did I wear it
I wore it like I've seen pictures of
this by the way around the internet like
way up and to the like you know what I
mean it was like it was like it off to
the side and up kind of a thing but [ __ ]
what was the less oh that was a
no the growing up a Long Island
everybody did that with their cars are
like everybody Jaya like a 1992 Honda
Civic and then put $6,000 into it so
that way you would know how cool you
look when you died in the drinking and
driving of course that was by remember
dude I had a 95 or 6 Chevy lumina first
car got the keys right the [ __ ] Best
Buy I got some [ __ ] pioneer 6x9 get
in the back got a new head unit [ __ ]
good night killing it you worked about
you ever steal from work when you were a
kid no but I did get fired funny trying
to get some speaker's fully I got fired
for theft from Best Buy but I didn't
actually steal so they were it was a
weird time when I was working there I
was like the only innocent man in
Shawshank are you talking to well listen
I get this is a two-prong thing so it's
just gonna be gonna be Fenian cannon
down in San Juan today okay so I was in
a I was in chess together
yeah the seasonal employee hold on
that's garbage right there if you've
ever been the seasonal employee that's
just a 16 year old trying to get money
for subs all right but so they write at
the same time they had this huge problem
with theft where they were like finally
they finally were able to like target it
was like this really tight investigation
they were having and they've lost
hundreds of thousands of dollars to like
an inside job so they were trying to
were looking at closely and so around
that time they I went I was in the back
in the warehouse and I noticed all of
these like Xbox games had been like cut
open and the discs were just missing it
was just the cases and I was back there
and I was looking for something else but
I was like holy [ __ ] these games are all
missing and then I'm like Here I am
touching them I don't want to be accused
of this so I walked them right up from
the back walked them right up to the
manager and was like hey this is all in
the back look at this and they were like
oh thank you so much for bringing it to
our attention
and then that week I went down to North
Carolina for I think Thanksgiving or
something like that and then or maybe
was like Christmas and then I
came I they called me while I was there
telling me that I was like fired and
because and then knew other people that
worked there and they told me that they
checked the tapes and from the tapes the
cameras in the way back of the warehouse
pointing this way so they only saw my
back and then they saw me touching these
games and then they saw the game
cartridges empty so then they thought
like he thought they thought that I was
this mastermind that was stealing these
Xbox games of being like wasn't me cuz
I'm turning it into you you know son is
a pretty good play though looking back
it isn't I did steal because what they
would have like CDs whenever the CDs
cases would get cracked even if the CD
was okay they would say to throw it in
the garbage
so rather than throw it I took some like
Jimmy Eat World CDs and a couple other
things but then it turns out the guy
that actually was stealing everything
who stole over two hundred thousand
dollars worth of product in the ten
years he worked there was this guy in
the camera department who they [ __ ]
loved who was named Buddy rod ironically
cheater and they just they made he was
like the beloved like you want to be
like this model employee and that was
the guy who was stealing how did you
ever hunt this guy down and get your
revenge for setting me up I mean I was I
was all right you know he's like it was
a [ __ ] that guy had a lot more to
lose I think that guy went to jail he
must as a reads like a [ __ ] became a
reason movie like real felony yeah well
I didn't I didn't really care about that
job that much you know in high school my
buddy used to work at footlocker and
talk about garbage he would tell us he'd
be like yellow but he needed cash right
everybody was stealing everything but
when he needed a little bit of [ __ ]
scratch he would tell everybody in
school you know what I mean he'd be like
yo I'm running come come through the
mall tonight I'm running the two for
seventy bill which is where you have to
you have to know your size you don't get
to try them on but you walk in and you
go I'll take those and those and he
would go and you tell him sighs he would
come out with them already in a bag come
up to the register give you like a fake
thing you hand them the cash okay I
didn't like we would just get shoes to
for 70 you just couldn't take Jordans or
Tim's because they had like their own
inventory system for them like they
double check those well like any Nikes
or Reeboks or anything you just go we
just get [ __ ] shoes and then they
finally got caught they're like yeah
they were down like you know $400,000 in
merchandise after like six months like
risen for
oh yeah I felony I think somebody did
because then they would all steal from
each other like the Jersey store like
sports favorites would trade you jerseys
for shoes lids would trade you this for
that it was all crazy the dynamics of
mall theft is a real trashy my buddy
works for a kiosk in the mall for a
proactive and he stole I mean thousands
and thousands of dollars
what's proact oh the like they say the
acne face cream he was moving that what
the [ __ ] that's true girls for a second
over here blemishes now he's trapped hey
pizza face get your hands over he's one
of those guys that grew up on my block
that didn't have they had a porch you
had to like cuz their house was like a
little elevated you needed to like go up
with stairs and a porch to get to their
front door so it was probably like if
you were standing was that like I level
the bottom of the door and they never
had the porch until I was like 15 so
they just kept going in through their
back yard or garage every day I'm like
get him on here destruction you know is
another one has anyone in your family
ever have you or anybody in your family
us tried to sell Cutco knives no
salesman no is a big one door to door
and pyramid scheme knife salesman well I
do have some of my kids that I grew up
on the block with are way way way into
Amway what's Amway Amway is the the
other pyramid scheme where you sell like
you sound like the [ __ ] like
supplements they you should just sell
like soap and now they sell like
supplements everything like energy
drinks and then it's all weirdly
associated with like Church and stuff so
it's very body and I don't get yeah yeah
but you you have friends that are doing
that yeah yeah that are like high level
like medallion diamond members which I
guess means they've taken advantage of
enough people I understand I don't know
yeah anything dude I went one time and
I was thinking college or whatever and
they were like I sold in the newspaper
like hey you know sales paid training
come in so I went in there was like 30
Schmucks all sitting in there with like
you know you your dad's suit on or
whatever
I've heard all CH everybody was like
then oh if I can get a sales job inside
it'd be good you know these were all
blue-collar guys trying to be trying to
get a white-collar job usually how it
works and the guy was like he just got
money from it was like slave ear was a
game and him it was just some [ __ ]
[ __ ] like blender we've chatted off
talk on people and he's like Lisi
brought me and he was listening you
hired I go oh great man thank you so
much like this is also maybe cuz alright
just give me a check for two hundred and
eighty-eight dollars for the Machine
upfront and then you're gonna pain you
don't work here you're now weird when
you have to pay to work somewhere I'm
like dude this is no no way I almost got
recruited into Scientology when I was in
college in Seattle
do you like what they had to say I would
have to Seattle for spring break because
we were thinking about moving out there
in the summer me and my buddy just to
spend the summer out there and we were
wandering around looking for jobs and
like we didn't even notice anything we
walked by this building that's how old
Foley is when you could wander around
and look for job anybody hiring
I'm strong as an ox and I and I get up
early every morning anybody hired I'm
strong as an ox and I've worked down by
the docks so I think we walked into this
place and like this like smoking hot
lady came up to us and just like
hypnotized us immediately and was just
like oh you know we're interested in
looking for people and they had us take
this test and like we took the test and
like we were sitting in there and like
just like if she was just asking us all
these questions I'm like I don't know if
you're gay or whatever yeah I like just
in my head you were something part-time
guys everything seasonal looking for
just ready to get a new head unit just
anything you guys offer Betty's what's
the deal here ya know and then all of a
sudden like we put it to
gather like cuz she went out and then
they brought this other guy in like the
next level guy to like talk to us and
are you happy and yeah something like
that and I remember we turned around and
we saw Dianetics l ron Hubbard's book
like on a wall I got like a bunch of
them and then we both look at each other
like it was like something on a [ __ ]
commie boiler coops get an e we [ __ ]
took off at the door I didn't know it
was just closed I didn't know what
Scientology was until like the South
Park episode of Scientology I think like
four years ago yeah that's what I'm
saying if in the 90s I stumbled into
some place with some hot chick ask me if
I'm happy I would have for sure joined
by them now cuz when I was a kid all you
saw was the book the commercial for the
book Dianetics by l ron hubbard it was
like volcanoes I thought it was just
like a science fiction absolutely a
science fiction I thought at first I
thought his name was Elrond like I
thought I didn't know it was hell dot
Ron I thought it was Elmer Superman like
you know ro and Elroy little a little
known fact the L actually stands for
Laquisha really I know he was German
yeah
all right let's pull it back here a
little bit a couple of simple questions
for you Feeny but they're important do
you shave before you take a shower or
after you take a shower there's only one
way to shave and it's obviously after no
nice or you're supposed to shave after
now you shave before no you don't you
shave after because we can your face we
know how the hot water starts to loosen
up and make everything major pores open
up yes your makes it easy to shave
you're supposed to shave after I shave
thank you still you still have little
pieces of hair everywhere no you don't
what I also I mean I'm this is the
longest my facial air I think has ever
been in my life so I don't I usually
keep it pretty clean shaven so I'm not
I'm not working with a ton much it takes
me less than three minutes to shave what
about a haircut are you can you go get a
haircut and then go out for the night
and you gotta take a shower in after you
get here
it depends I'd prefer to take a shower
if I can't because I hate the little
piece of hair but sometimes I do a
really good job [ __ ] clean it up yeah
but I will say this I don't go to
barbershops I go to salons you do yeah
so I just know what I need okay you get
a shampoo you get a shampoo you get a
head massage you get a free drink while
you're waiting can be wine could be
cucumber water could be whatever you
want and also they don't barbershops
don't have layering scissors my problem
this is like the most like you know
first world problems my hair actually
gets too thick so I have to have it wow
really
terrible yeah here donor you should talk
to Feeny yeah it's just too thick and
lustrous I'm not sure what I could you
know right now you can see it gets like
if I grew there all it out it just looks
like a big helmet you listen I go to a
[ __ ] barber shop a guy who barely
speaks English like a man you and the
other Queens can state the hair salon
alright that's why your that's why
you're low-rent you know hippies only in
that kibby's only in there for two
minutes
[Laughter]
sit down [ __ ] a strong wind all of a
sudden you're like dude before I eat my
hair even started thinning in the front
I was in like Heist I was in college
freshman year at college my buddy was
shaving my head music you have like
dolls like this is like baby hair both
in let's stop I know did your mom ever
cut your hair when you were a kid she
tried once and butchered it so bad that
it was like a scarring moment for us
like here's the garbage here's real
garbage did you over cut your mom's hair
but my mom also worked in salons growing
up that's why I go to salons I was very
comfortable there so I would always get
like free haircuts by like professional
hair stylists that's too funny it's
pretty good you got one more we'll get
this guy off the hook I got one more I'm
trying to think of how to stick the
landing here cuz I know he's garbage but
I want to know
Maude I have something that I feel like
will really incriminate me
all right I got two quick ones just you
know has anyone in your family owned a
waterbed
my parents just means that we're [ __ ]
baby and then me you are there's even
get there's did you no no I went from we
both had water beds in the house at the
same time I went for you guys I went
from a car bed I went from a car bed you
were one of those kids I was like a
convertible car bed I was you were rich
I went from a car bed to a waterbed
that's what I went to I skip I went
right to 70s porn star I see everything
that's in the same water beds are the
greatest thing on the planet they're
great for your back they're also there's
nothing better than when it's you cook I
used to crank the AC to like you'd be
like 62 degrees and then you have you're
laying on a hundred and one degrees
worth of water and it's yeah you [ __ ]
tuck in and it's like so hot but then
it's freezing it's it was the greatest
there's the greatest thing good water
beds where I had one in high school man
shirt they're so awesome I'm sure you
can still get them not new they're not I
bet I hope I got with my [ __ ] money
on the line they're not making new water
beds yeah we bought the whole family we
were a waterbed family that's that's
that's the craziest thing I've ever
heard in my life we were a waterbed
family did your [ __ ] trap you're all
land for your whole family or [ __ ]
garbage people you mix a little lice
into that mix you got [ __ ] serious
never had lice never never had lice we
voice but we did have we did have this
is gonna really I think acrimony me we
did have a pool so classy dependent of
above-ground pool friends my friend
you're among friends not here I was a
in-ground pool kind of guy Wow
guests in a row that had an above-ground
pool and I tell you what I tell
everybody Mikey I prefer them
okay I've said old deeds he tried that
he died starting to die on this [ __ ]
mountain every time we thought I don't
want to hit my head on some concrete
Moroccan mommy went in there we would
always go into we would go pool partying
at my neighbor's house who had the
in-ground pool and a diving board mine
was like hey you guys want to climb into
my tub with me no way dude
no gonna take a ladder up and then you
just and then when you try and take the
ladder the whole side is gonna get
off-balance you're gonna fall in the
pool - you can't swivel you hit them
laps in a [ __ ] above-ground no but
you got I tell you what you can do it
above-ground pool that you can't do and
I know where you're going and I fully
agree or like the whirlpool oh yeah
there you get a [ __ ] mean whirlpool
going an above-ground pool try to swim
the other way is a little kid who cares
if you can't afford Dorney Park you got
it right in your backyard baby [ __ ] at
Six Flags baby let's do it
Mike Feeny buddy thank you so much for
for hanging out with us today and I
think we determined kids garbage I'm
going 72 and a third percent garbage
okay yeah I'll say you're 85% garbage
but not cuz I'll tell you what now he
did he knows what he's doing he makes
not when he's at home he makes nice
cocktails when he goes out he knows how
to handle himself in a restaurant he
always gives me good this guy is never
missed with a restaurant tip and a story
of where to go to it my girl I'm telling
you every time this alone I mean you
were a hundred percent the salons
a--that's a classy thing to do you know
you did have a motorized couch it's
broken I'll look past that a little bit
you know I'm an enigma you know he takes
good care of himself he's got the
decorations hanging in the room I see
he's seventy seventy two and a third
I'll go and by the way I forgot to tell
you Mike Nick at the at the waterbed
store told me to tell you to say hello
thank you for the business yeah of
course
Mikey what do you have coming up you got
a new patreon that you're doing with
that mr. Mike Cannon and our good pal
Brendon Sangalo yes we started a new
patreon podcast since the world has
ended in comedy is no more and none of
us have any means of income
and we were doing a patreon podcast
called what's the scenario and in that
we tackle various like what-if scenarios
hypotheticals that we can talk about
which quickly devolves into all of us
fighting we launched it a week ago so
check that out but if you want to check
out some free stuff just to dip your toe
in the Mike Feeny water and see if you
you know before you want to commit I
know Mike Feeny above-ground pool
Mike Feeny comedy dot-com at I am Mike
Feeny on social media Irish goodbye
podcast is free and also Rage Against
routine is the album available now
everywhere very nice I love it buddy
thank you so much this was so much fun
kidnap me this is great what do we got
to tell them guys I cannot stress enough
thank you so much for all the support
we've received so far getting the crown
all the rating reviewing subscribing
really appreciate it if you haven't
please do already please share with a
friend you know help us keep this
pushing this ball up the hill we really
appreciate it
follow me on all social medias at kevin
ryan comedy awesome guys thank you so
much we'll be we'll be back with a brand
new episode on are you garbage and don't
forget to check out your daily dose of
the hard feelings podcast with me mine
every single [ __ ] day of the
quarantine we are gonna be there for you
we thank you guys again so much and
we'll see you soon
ie boys see you guys great job